So, I'd like to spend a few minutes with you folks today...
...imagining what our planet might look like in a thousand years.
But before I do that, I need to talk to you about synthetic materials like plastics,...
...which require huge amounts of energy to create...
...and, because of their disposal issues, are slowly poisoning our planet.
I also want to tell you and share with you how my team and I have been using mushrooms over the last three years.
Not like that.
We're using mushrooms to create an entirely new class of materials,...
...which perform a lot like plastics during their use,...
...but are made from crop waste and are totally compostable at the end of their lives.
Because in nature, mushrooms are the recycling system.
And what we've discovered is that by using a part of the mushroom you've probably never seen,...
...analogous to its root structure, it's called "mycelium",...
...we can actually grow materials with many of the same properties of conventional synthetics.
Now, mycelium is an amazing material, because it's a self-assembling material...
...it actually takes things we would consider waste,...
...things like seed husks or woody biomass,...
...and can transform them into a chitinous polymer,...
...which you can form into almost any shape.
In our process, we basically use it as a glue.
And by using mycelium as a glue,...
...you can mold things just like you do in the plastic industry,...
...and you can create materials with many different properties,...
...materials that are insulating, fire-resistant, moisture-resistant, vapor-resistant,...
...materials that can absorb impacts, that can absorb acoustical impacts.
But these materials are grown from agricultural byproducts, not made out of petroleum.
And because they're made of natural materials,...
...they're 100 percent compostable in your own backyard.